it takes a village to bring down a
Supreme Court nomination and that's what
these protesters at the US Capitol are
asking for allegations of sexual
misconduct have cast a pall over Brett
Kavanaugh president Trump's nominee to
the Supreme Court in the era of me too
these people aren't taking it lightly
it's time to listen to women it's been
time to listen to women for like
thousands of years at this point
but finally since the woman's March that
was the largest global demonstration in
world history
were actually coming together it's no
longer he said she said but I believe
that men should be held accountable and
should do anything in their power to
correct any injustice --is that they
have committed in their past and I
believe that hiding behind power and
patriarchy is wrong and I believe that
men should stand up if they had
committed wrongs and admit that the
protest was coordinated by several
different activist groups including the
same people who put together the massive
women's March that swept the world last
year as one of the leaders of the
women's March it's important for us to
ensure that the movement that we created
on January 21st 2017 translates into
action and in this particular moment
it's important for women and allies to
be out here it's a very important moment
in our generation Cavanagh cannot get on
the Supreme Court he will roll us back
to decades on things that folks before
us fought very hard for us to have and
I'm here because I don't want my
daughters to have less rights than I
have the specter of the midterm
elections coming up in less than two
months hangs over everything Republicans
fear they could lose their control of
both houses of Congress despite flagging
public support for the president's
nominee Republicans have stood by him
the stories that Cavanaugh's accusers
tell are difficult to prove but these
protesters believe them I absolutely
believe her the fact that it's now been
corroborated or his actions have been
corroborated by other women is good but
I was fine with just that one woman and
I wonder how many other women in his
adult life have also been harassed or
worse by him the first the first
accusation should should be enough to
have him with withdraw withdrawn the
second is just now embarrassing at this
point
painful and he should be gone I mean I
hope to accomplish that that we start
treating these women with with some kind
of seriousness and respect I don't think
they came out of nowhere I think they're
I think they're for real I'm not for
ruining anybody's life but if they've
ruined these woman's if he's ruined
these women's lives and we need to talk
about this one of the accusers are
scheduled to testify later this week to
the Senate Judiciary Committee in the
face of growing hostility Cavanaugh and
the Republicans have indicated they will
not give up without a fight
neither are these activists